you work here yeah how old are you 13.
oh my God is that even allowed in this
viral Tick Tock we allegedly hear a 13
year old working at a Chick-fil-A owned
by his dad the union advocacy group that
posted it says that kids are working
dangerous jobs because taking
drive-through orders and slinging waffle
fries at a Chick-fil-A your dad owns
sounds like the definition of danger but
working as a teenager is actually a path
to having a successful career and
there's research to Backside up one 2016
study for example found the teenagers
who worked 20 hours a week during their
senior year earned about 12 percent more
after they graduated than their
non-working peers and the teenagers who
have jobs feel the benefits as one high
school student told the New York Times
my job has helped me in many ways I was
super shy before I started and now I am
more confident with myself stop treating
teenagers like delicate flowers let them
work make money and learn some life
skills